autism today is diagnosed behaviorally
there's no blood tests that a physician
can order or to a diagnose the condition
or B determine which children are at
risk for developing autism those don't
exist in the marketplace and that's what
we're bringing to market what's up
everyone we are at Indy bio demo day we
are back and we are with John Slattery
from bio Rosa yeah thanks for having
them I'm super excited to talk to you
thank you bio Ross is so important so
let's let's start by ok let's start by
just giving a very basic understanding
so it's is it's early stage diagnosis of
autism pediatrics and children so right
so autism today is diagnosed
behaviorally there's no blood tests that
a physician can order or to a diagnose
the condition or B determine which
children are at risk for developing
autism those don't exist in the
marketplace and that's what we're
bringing to market by doing so it'll you
know research continually shows that if
children get diagnosed with autism early
and they get into behavioral services
early they have better outcomes but the
same tools that we're developing for
diagnosis by understanding the biology
of disease we can actually have a
resurgence in trying to figure out
treatments that affect the biology to
improve behavior and we have some
interesting and compelling data on that
already which is super exciting and
we're looking to further expand that
with that actually I'm funny so okay and
let's as we go into more of the of the
nuance of this because we are gonna
unpack that I want to know you better
how did you get passionate about this
yeah so I was introduced to autism when
I was about 16 years old one of my best
friends whose wedding I was in a couple
years back his brother has a severe
form of autism to the point where I
would go over to their house during high
school see holes in the wall where he
would have like aggressive episodes it
was it was very heart-wrenching that a
family had to deal with a child that was
so behaviorally you know impaired that
it affected the whole entire family unit
he didn't interact with people normally
kind of classic autism we'd refer to it
as communication and social impairment
restricted and repetitive interests and
he met kind of the Cardinal symptoms of
autism he kinda had scripted speech he
would he could tell you just amazingly
every single if you walked into his room
every single flag from around the world
was in his room and he could tell you
about anything and everything you wanted
to know about each place on the earth he
would watch the same shows over and over
again he could not interact socially so
it just really put a passion in me an
intrigue of what makes someone's brain
function that way and while he's so
impacted and won't be able to have a job
and won't be able to live you know a
normal productive life in society but
there's these things that he could do
that none of us could do so I was like
by understanding autism what could that
mean for how the brain works how what
could it mean in terms of better
interacting or understanding how people
interact with each other and just kind
of getting a better understanding of
brain function which is really what got
me started on a career in neuroscience
so that's kind of where it started and
then I was fortunate enough to be able
to kind of bring things full circle and
work on really cutting-edge autism
research in my hometown the Rock
Arkansas is where I'm from that's what
Arkansas Children's Hospital is and
while most people were focusing on the
genetic basis of autism or doing eye
tracking technology is a brain imaging
or eg is all these different things this
group in Arkansas said huh
we think that autism is metabolic and
they started finding these peculiar
abnormalities in the wealth in the way
cells communicate and the way that
things like the mitochondria function
and seeing all these different
disturbances and biochemistry which Jill
James who's a co-founder in our company
said huh there's some really interesting
peculiar biology going on here I wonder
if we could improve the biology of the
disorder and that was just her first
question and she realized that she could
and then she goes okay will by changing
the biology does that also improved the
child's behavior and function and lo and
behold it was happening to where
children were in clinical trials and
responding then we started kind of going
full street press on that it had some
really really interesting results which
we're hoping to further expand on it
with bye Rosa awesome that's such a good
story of getting involved because man
does it really take a just a profound
sort of like wake up to like a serious
heart and gut wrenching problem in a
family to really be like I am so
passionate about about like solved yeah
and then clinically when we saw all
these kids you know we sold thousands of
kids over that seven years that I was
there from from all around the world it
was pretty remarkable we kind of created
this multidisciplinary autism clinic
dedicated to the medical needs of these
kids these kids have a lot of
comorbidities they they have GI problems
a lot of them have seizures a lot of
them are really medically fragile and we
think that's because their metabolic
systems or metabolic or are very fragile
so there's ways in which you can treat
the biology to improve behavior but one
thing we really need to do and you know
research showed over and over again as
if you could diagnose earlier it's gonna
relate to a better prognosis for that
child and then that that's literally
that's the gatekeeper to opening up a
whole new world in which we could start
diagnosing different treating it
biologically and allowing these kids to
actually respond to behavioral
interventions in ways that they can't
because their own biology is fighting
against them and some
yes yeah so let's talk about the the
actual metabolic markers okay so let's
talk about those and then let's talk
about how what you're making is able to
detect that yeah yeah cool yes so these
are really foundational biochemical
pathways they're involved in every cell
in the body so they are involved in what
we call one carbon folate metabolism
which is a very complex interconnected
set of pathways that are involved in
things that are extremely important for
normal physiology and the developing
brain is very vulnerable to anything
right so if there's problems in these
metabolic pathways or metabolic blocks
if you will it's gonna greatly impact
the brain more and affects other parts
of the body and one thing that's really
interesting about the brain is that even
though it's only 2% of body mass it
receives over 20% of the oxygen supply
so your heart's constantly pumping to
make sure your brain is always getting
glucose and oxygen yeah and if there's
metabolic blocks it can impact cellular
function and we're seeing problems and
things that are related to gene
expression like epigenetics folate
metabolism which you know every woman
during pregnancy goes on folic acid
supplementation because we know how
important it is for neural development
but these kids are seeing we're seeing
problems in folate metabolism so they're
not properly able to utilize folate the
way they're supposed to we're also
seeing problems and things that we call
redox which is the primary antioxidant
ourselves is called glutathione it's
kind of this God molecule if you will so
problems in glutathione can actually
cause something refer to as oxidative
stress an oxidative stress is kind of
this smoking gun if you will of problems
and that that impacts like your
mitochondria which are the central
metabolic you know regulators and that
if there's problems there
well the developing brain requires a ton
of energy in order to properly develop
the way it's supposed to so if you have
oxidative stress impacting them
Andreea it's gonna affect the way that
the brain is able to develop and
function because it's not getting the
proper to proper energy supply it needs
and then we're also seeing problems in
what we call purine pathways and purines
and pyrimidines are the building blocks
for DNA so all of these pathways are
connected and we're seeing disturbances
in all of them and the novelty of what
we're doing is that we can take a small
amount of blood and run marker and we do
you know machine learning on the data
but we get the signal from something
called mass spec and do like a
metabolomic approach then we can
determine based on the metabolic
signature which children have autism and
which ones don't
with really good accuracy and the
accuracy is actually just as good or
better than behavioral diagnosis we
can't replace behavioral diagnosis until
we're able to further validate our
approach yes but we think this may have
the potential field to detect autism
biochemically and put kids into services
before they ever even develop symptoms
of the disorder which would greatly
improve their prognosis
we know that children that if they get
diagnosed before age 2 there's this
period of synaptic pruning in the brain
where if you get kids in early before
that it's kind of like a window that's
shutting right there's this period of
pruning yep and if you can get kids in
before that shuts certain kids actually
recover from autism because you can
diagnose and put them in that very
intensive behavioral interventions and
the brands very plastic yes yes and then
they actually can have a much better
response potential but unfortunately
most kids miss out on that 100 we're
talking about like three years old yes
most kids you know a parent
spec's a problem as early as 12 months
most kids are not diagnosed until four
four and a half or even older
get them young you can get the right
behavioral therapies in so so tell us
about the metabolic signature can we
talk about what are the specifics on
that that I can't really talk about the
specific workers you know but yeah it's
it's involved in those pathways okay and
then machine learning helps us determine
the critical pieces of those pathways
that are necessary to predict which
which sample came from autism or not and
then the other really cool thing about
this is not only is it kind of a binary
distribution of yes it came from autism
or no it didn't the markers also autism
is a spectrum disorder and we're seeing
that the severity of the metabolic
phenotype of the child correlates with
their behavioral phenotype so that we
can actually see that how severe their
you know metabolic system is impaired
that correlates with how behaviorally
they're impaired yes which is remarkable
so that allows for a really great
opportunity at being able to get a
baseline of you know how severely
affected they are then if we start
seeing changes in these markers over
time yes that correlates with a
meaningful clinical response we've
actually seen that in clinical trials it
just needs to be done much more and at a
greater scale so that we could actually
start integrating it into clinical
practice and so is the metabolic test a
what is it a small blood yeah very small
amount and and what age would you
recommend are you so we're doing a
validation study in which we're putting
our biomarkers and algorithms up against
the current gold standard which is that
one-on-one interaction between a child a
therapist yes to validate it against you
know what is the gold standard today
yeah yeah that's so big jump what we're
doing is enrolling children between the
ages of 18 months and 60 months so that
way if we detect a signal we can be able
to take those 18 month olds before that
period at you know age 2 or 24 months
put them into services faster and we
will have a chance of making sure that
more children have a chance
of an optimal outcome where certain
children actually recover from their
autism to where if you did a behavioral
diagnostic test on them after we
intervened during that time they
wouldn't they wouldn't meet
qualification criteria for autism
anymore they'd fall off the spectrum we
want to make sure more of those cases
occur and then we also feel that by
addressing the biology of the disease or
disorder
we actually have an even greater chance
of children that miss out on that window
of opportunity to really moving a needle
on them to improve their systems in
their body to try and really improve
their quality of life and and have a
much better outcome as possible today
and what is the behavioral therapy that
is applied then yeah so the leading
autism behavioral treatment is called
applied behavioral analysis so it comes
from and are you would you take that
would you work with that oh actually
that yeah yeah one of our goals as a
company is to align with one of the
leading apply wave analysis goes by ABA
one of our go-to-market strategies is to
align with ABA partners to make sure
that you know they can only do ABA once
the child's been diagnosed but there's a
wait list all across the country and
around the world depending on where you
are and how high-throughput clinic is
yeah kids are waiting anywhere between
three months and 24 months so parents
make more training that we need more
trophy you have you have more kids that
need to be evaluated for autism then
there are practitioners that can do the
diagnosis so it just creates a
bottleneck and jam in the system and we
need the available diagnose exactly yeah
so that way if we diagnose earlier well
the only way the kids can begin ABA
which is covered by insurance and 48
states then we can be able to have our
tests put them into ABA faster and so
that we don't have to wait anymore if
you have a high reason to believe that a
child is at risk for autism you can do a
screening tool like ours and put them
into services faster
it will unfortunately have to be self
pay until insurance covers it but it's
something that allow it allows the
opportunity to where insurance will
cover some level of the treatment we
just wouldn't know how much but it
allows kids access to fast - faster
therapy when they need it the most
which is critical you know yep and then
what is the just you give us a brief
understanding of what even what occurs
with the child in ABA yes so it's
something called discrete trial learning
where it's basically like each behavior
that a child has you take that behavior
you basically deconstruct it and then
teach the trial bit-by-bit how to build
the appropriate behavior and then
reinforce them on doing appropriate
behaviors to ensure that they're
learning the correct way to interact
with people and things and you know
their surroundings interesting so what
no no I'm interested to hear your
thought about this and I've kind of
poked in this area of neural diversity
for a while and there are videos of that
you that you showed me - and that you
have been we've seen now of children
that have severe motor impairments where
they're doing it stemming and things
like that and that is okay that's an
absolute obvious like that is hurting
them okay and then there's the maybe we
let's call it an opposite which is like
they're obsessed with all of the flags
and all of the countries in the room and
they can tell you all these stats about
figures fat and facts about them how if
it's that may be mild if they give let's
call it mild if it is mild and they're
just obsessed with the specific thing
like that maybe they're meant to be
genius in that thing and especially so
so what so yeah yeah so I mean the type
of autism that we're looking to truly
move the needle on for kids
our kids that they have they will not be
able to live an independent functional
life yeah unfortunately until we do
something that can dramatically improve
their their prognosis there are things
that are very interesting that we're
starting to learn that some of these
children while if you test them on you
know normal IQ tests they'll bottom out
and you'll think that you know the kid
you know meets criteria for maybe like a
mental retardation but if you actually
test that child in a way in which they
can interact meaningfully like a
storyboard where you actually can go
with a child I've seen kids that can't
speak yeah but the parent takes them
over to a storyboard where they say
what's 1 million seven hundred and
sixty-five divided by fourteen I
couldn't tell you off the top of my head
no way these kids will go over there and
move the storyboard to the exact number
and I can get our calculator and they're
correct yeah so they are not children
that are you know mentally [ __ ]
their genius level it's just they're
trapped in and can't express it the way
if they want to yeah or the way we want
them to so imagine how stressful that
must be to the child yes if I couldn't
interact with my surroundings and I
couldn't communicate what I wanted to
and I knew the answers how would you
respond I'll be pretty upset and you
know probably do things that appeared to
be aggressive behavior or you know be
attempt to temper tantrum or something
like that or just have a meltdown I mean
that that's a normal response so maybe
there's certain aspects of these kids
that they're they're normal but we
consider their behavior abnormal but
what if we going to prove their biology
to make sure that that what we consider
abnormal can actually have a better
chance at being normal in the more
adaptive culture exactly
yeah so interesting I'm just I'm loving
where the potentials of evolution in the
most beautiful ways are evolving but
also in the ones that are like you
initially started describing it with the
inability to properly independently
function in a society right yeah it
needs to be tackled it does because I
mean the estimated costs society per
year on dealing with these super
impaired kids it's 30 billion dollars a
year whoa and the autism rates today in
this country or one in 59 Wow back in
the 70s it was one in five thousand yes
has moved up by two minutes or two main
- yeah and one in forty two boys in this
country so yeah and around the world if
it also moving that quickly in
westernized countries yes why that is we
don't truly know there's no you have to
do with the use of computer technology
there's some really interesting theories
on it we've written a few papers that
kind of combine certain theories in
terms of what might be going on but what
we're seeing from a biochemical
perspective you know we're not saying
that this is the cause it's just
something that can be leveraged as a
better diagnostic tool and something
that can be used to monitor patient
progress over time so you know there's
the bottom line with autism of what's
causing it the answers many many things
we can look at problems in the genome
and know that there's hundreds of genes
involved then there's also not nuclear
DNA where we you know you do like you
know looking at chromosomal microarrays
and things like that to look for genetic
polymorphisms we're seeing problems in
mitochondrial DNA and not necessarily
mitochondria main point mutations but we
call heteroplasmy where the amount of
good mitochondria per cell is different
in a patient with autism versus a
patient that's normal versus a patient
that has even diabetes and then there's
problems in this new emerging concept
called the microbiome and we seem to
have to see problems there
I'd say that's causal but it seems to be
associated with autism especially kids
with autism have gi
disturbances and there's some really
interesting data on trying to manipulate
the microbiome in order to improve GI
symptoms and behavioral symptoms and we
have some data that shows that our
markers seem to move in response to even
something that wouldn't even affect our
targets but they're off target which is
the microbiome if they're producing
small molecules that can affect our own
metabolism then by improving the
microbiome we can actually improve the
way our own body functions and decrease
certain problems with brain function
that may be a result of problems in that
gut ecosystem there's you just listing
all these variables that actually go
into the equation and it just to someone
that cares a lot about nuance and multi
variability is so tough to actually ya
alkylate yeah and that's that's one of
the things that our algorithms use is a
multivariate analytic approach to taking
kind of disparate sources of information
and being able to kind of pull it
together what's what's the signal from
the noise and be able to leverage that
in a useful way to try and monitor
disease state and progression over time
as Wells responds we feel that the same
sort of approach with autism kind of
being this amalgam of all these things
that can go wrong during the wrong time
during development leading to an
increased risk in autism that the same
sort of thing can be applied to other
disorders of their chronic disease I'm a
firm believer that the same sort of
abnormalities that we're seeing in
autism where it's problems with the
mitochondria problems with oxidative
stress problems with the gut microbiome
all of these things are interconnected
systems when certain aspects of the body
break down it promotes other diseases
and one one that we think really
strongly seems to be associated with
autism later in life that it's not
autism but it's a different phenotypic
expression it's actually Parkinson's
disease there's a lot of really really
interesting data showing that
patients with Parkinson's disease have
problems with oxidative stress they have
problems with the mitochondria that
problems with the gut microbiome and
that all of these things can accumulate
over time and that those problems end up
breaking down you know neurons and in
the substantia [ __ ] and dopamine
production and all these other things
but that's an that may be an output of
the body it may not be the initial
causal factor we think it we consider it
that way because you end up seeing
behavioral symptoms lot of Parkinson's
with rigidity all these different things
but what if it's actually starting in
the gut and breaking down the metabolic
systems with mitochondria what if that's
actually the the factors that happen way
before the development of Parkinson's
and we actually see that patients that
have Parkinson's a lot of them have high
rates of constipation we see the same
thing in autism so I think we're gonna
have a lot of lessons learned with what
we learn from autism of being this kind
of microcosm of all these things can go
wrong at the wrong points or in
development leading to autism but other
factors of chronic disease across the
life line there may be similar shared
mechanisms going on and what we are able
to discover from autism we can apply to
other things yes and what other people
learn can apply to you exactly yeah the
the whole idea of of of like digitally
diagnosing a developing disease is
something that is so fascinating so how
does bio Rossa get into the hands of
parents so the first thing we need to do
is a validation study against the gold
standard so the last thing we want to do
is bring a product to market that has
not been rigorously tested against the
gold standard let's see reason being it
does succeed yeah yeah yeah and then
what okay yeah okay because we don't
want to bring a product to market that
would not be rigorously tested totally
because autism is a scary thing and
nothing drives me more crazy than people
trying to take advantage
of desperate parents told that's it
makes me very angry worse
so we upon validation we will be able to
bring our product to market as a
screening tool where children that are
looking to get assessed for an autism
diagnosis at developmental centers they
will be able to get the BIOS a test
while they're waiting in line so to
speak and so that way all children will
have access to the test our goal as a
company is to make sure that's available
to all children whether they can afford
it or not and that good for those that
can't afford it it will be $500 self-pay
and then until the in turn until
insurance covers the cost of the tests
we're also selling it to groups or
developing treatments for autism in
biotech and pharma as well as academia
so it that way
we can hopefully accelerate drug
development to bring the first
fda-approved interventions to market for
these kids as well and then like a
scholarship system or something knows
that cannot yeah so I mean fundamentally
what we're doing to try and improve
lives for kids with autism that's what
it's all about exact and then we want to
take some of our own money and put it
back into more autism research yes from
when we are profitable to make sure that
we can accelerate novel new therapies
because the problem is not going away
and we need to we need to change the
system and make it better to improve
patients lives and what would be
something to do we do we think there's
something else that we should tell
people about what you're making when
you're building on the way out there's
something else that's yeah I mean we
have the ability and opportunity at hand
to be able to potentially prevent autism
altogether
that's not to say that you know it's
gonna work for every patient but for and
when we say autism we're talking about
those super severe kids totally it won't
be able to live independent functional
lives the other side of the coin is that
if we're able to have a better tool that
we can bring clinicians to where they
can monitor patient progress rate will
help facilitate drug development the
millions of kids over 30 million that
are affected by autism that's 30 million
children there's over 100 million people
affected by autism and adults so massive
market opportunity but we're looking to
also work on facilitating drug
development and discovery so that way
the people that are affected we can also
move the needle on them too and make
sure they have a more productive life
one of the worst things as a parent of a
child with a super impaired kid is
what's gonna happen when I'm gone who's
gonna look after my child those are
terrible fears for parents totally I
made them promise these families a long
time ago that we're gonna do something
to make sure that that's not as scary a
thought in the future and that's exactly
what we need to do I love it thank you
so much sure thank you so much for
working on this it's my passion there's
a problem
Hey these kids need better the families
need better and we're aiming to do that
so thanks for teaching us about it yeah
sure man thank you thank you awesome
thank you
[Music]